you are what will produce including
[Music]
hi welcome to another ColdFusion video
as most of you probably already know
nASA has just recently announced the
discovery of seven earth-sized planet in
another solar system within our galaxy
here are the details the star system
called Trappist 1 is about 40 light
years or 380 trillion kilometres away
from Earth now that may sound far but in
the astronomical terms that's actually
really close right in our backyard but
still the fastest moving man-made object
the Juno spacecraft would take 158
thousand years to get there to get there
in a reasonable amount of time using our
current understanding of physics we
either have to travel at the speed of
light or bend space-time itself to
create a wormhole both of which were
nowhere near figuring out these seven
planets are said to be rocky in nature
and orbit very close to an ultra-cool
dwarf star to give you an idea of how
close together they are if Trappist one
was our star all seven planets would be
within Mercury's orbit mercury is the
closest planet to the Sun in our solar
system the main excitement and buzz
around this is that three of the planets
are on the so called Goldilocks zone
that is an area of orbit from the host
star that is neither too hot or too cold
to support liquid water this zone is
said to be habitable for life the orbits
of these three planets take six nine and
twelve days respectively to circulate
around the small star for clarity and
definition
planets outside of our solar system are
defined by the term exoplanet this
recently discovered solar system is
unique because no other system that we
know contains so many earth-sized
exoplanet so the question is how did
NASA do it astronomers use the spitzer
space telescope to make the discovery
this telescope looks at infrared
wavelength which glow from the Takas one
star and can detect when a planet passes
in front of it the telescope is able to
detect this because the glow from the
star gets a tiny bit dimmer each time a
planet
crosses in front of its class from this
data they could estimate the mass and
density of these planets in total the
Spitzberg spacecraft monitored the solar
system for about 500 hours traditionally
in the 20th century exoplanets were
originally found by the wobble that they
induced in a star as their gravitational
pull affected it this method only just
allowed us to know that these planets
existed for a visual example check out
the wobble of the star on the left in
this artist representation nowadays in
the 21st century we can analyze in much
more detail here's how it's done when
light from a star passes through the
atmospheric horizon of a planet and
travels trillions of kilometres to us
that light is affected by gases in the
alien planet's atmosphere the different
wavelengths of light are absorbed by
different gases by analyzing the light
spectrum we can actually gain insight
into the chemical composition and likely
makeup of that atmosphere that's not bad
for being trillions of kilometres away
now the funny thing about all of this is
that the script the telescope which has
launched back in 2003 was never supposed
to be operational for this long the
craft wasn't even planned to do any of
this so how does this telescope actually
communicate back with scientists on
earth the telescope actually follows the
orbit of the earth but are just slightly
slower speed as the craft gets further
away from us
it's an turn after point at increasingly
higher angles to communicate with us
unfortunately at the same time this
higher angle of tilt results in less
sunlight reaching the solar panels of
the craft this means that there's less
powers of the telescope so eventually
we're going to lose communication with
the craft because it would lose power
completely but this isn't the end of
things like in 2018 NASA will be
launching the James Webb telescope this
is a massive leap forward in all
previous effort and from this telescope
will actually be able to see images of
the distant planet
part of the Spitzer's extended mission
is to scout out new areas for the James
Webb telescope to look at in more detail
it's kind of like passing on the baton
between two telescopes one final point
of interest that you might like to know
is that believe it or not
x-ray planet hunting is actually very
recent the first exoplanet was
discovered in 1995 and its name was 51
pegasi B this planet was a hot unkind
place very close to its parent star and
about half the size of Jupiter since
then thousands of exoplanets have been
found this is really a testament to how
smart was gotten over the past quarter
century but it's more a measure of how
technology has improved allowing us to
be able to detect more planets it
doesn't stop there though recent
statistical estimates say that there's
at least one planet around every star in
our galaxy that's something like a truly
an exoplanet in our galaxy alone
many of these are earth sized lifetime
is fascinating all in all it kind of
makes you feel small in a way pretty
much every part of world history every
person you've ever heard about or known
and all things relative to us throughout
time have just happened on this tiny
planet which is a microscopic part of a
much bigger picture anyway that was just
a quick video highlighting NASA's latest
discovery I hope you found that
interesting and learn something from
that if you've just stumbled across this
channel feel free to subscribe this has
been - go go you're been watching cold
fusion thanks for watching and I'll
catch you again soon for the next video
Cheers
have a good one cold fusion
it's me thinking
[Music]
you